I'm going to explain to you what's
really behind all these calls on Capitol
Hill suddenly for Al Franken to resign
from the Senate at last count 34
Democratic senators look at them all
they're are demanding that Franken step
down in the wake of a string of
harassment allegations that we've been
hearing about now for days now before
you join the march up the castle to the
Castle Frankenstein to capture the
monster I have a word of caution they've
come down with a sudden case of feverish
morality but what it really is is
nothing more than a political
calculation by the Dems look they have
two paths to destroy the president the
first is the mauler investigation we've
been talking about how that's corrupt to
the core
last night with Gene Erie yet another
prosecutor who shouldn't be on this case
we broke that story exclusively last
night on the show the second way they're
gonna try to destroy the trump
presidency is the war on women yeah that
old saw they have now determined that
it's worth sacrificing Franken just like
they did John Conyers throw them
overboard to save the political Titanic
that is their party now one what does
this do it sets the precedent for the
Democrats to try to drive Roy Moore from
office should he win the Alabama Senate
race and to this is the next step in the
quest to impeach President Trump the
left is brilliant they're really really
smart at using the media to create a
narrative and pound it all day long that
quickly becomes a political bludgeon the
drumbeat of accusations and the calls
for scalps advance the false premise
that the left are all about protecting
women in fact you know both Hollywood
and the Democrats think about this
they've objectified and pornified and
abused women for decades and the abusers
let's not forget have been celebrated
Ted
Kennedy Bill Clinton Matt Lauer Kevin
Spacey Frank and Conyers Weinstein the
list goes on and on so I'll tell you
this tonight the weary of the lynch mob
that you joined today because tomorrow
it could be coming for your husband your
brother your son and yes even your
president and that's the angle